aber war dame ist luca meine damen und
herren ich sitze hier mal wieder nicht
alleine sondern mit sexy sondern wie
spielen heute ein spiel namens k k
das habe ich mir in einer bibliothek
tatsächlich gekauft
bei diesem spiel geht es darum dass wir
eine toilette haben das ist die hier und
in die natur dieses mit kaka mit einem
spiel geht es darum dass diese person
namens mister kaká in die toilette rein
auf jeden fall befindet sich mister kaka
nun in dieser band und wir haben hier
einen würfel mit den saiten 123 und noch
mal ein zwei drei der kommt hier oben in
sonst einfach rein und wir würfel nun
abwechselnd zum beispiel ich habe jetzt
eine 1 gewürfelt das heißt ich müsste
einmal hier drauf drücken wenn esther
kaka dann drin stecken bleibt dann ist
sein wenn er halt nicht rausgeflogen
kommt dann wird die mülheimer wieder
rein fakten und sandra werden der reihe
wenn sandra drei würfeln würde und
musste drei mal drauf drückt und besser
kaka fliegt raus
dann müssen wir uns darum streiten und
kämpfen wärme ist der kater als erstes
denkt beim massaker in der luft fangen
sollte dann bekommt man zwei chips von
diesen chips die wir hier vorbereitet
haben wir haben zehn chips insgesamt und
wenn man meister kk fängt eine haufen
boden ist also nicht fängt sondern wenn
er schon auf dem boden liegt und man
nimmt ihn dann dann vielleicht man einen
ja wir spielen nun auf jeden fall drei
komplette runden durch also dreimal die
10 chips werden wir verteilen
und nach jeder runde schauen sie wer
weniger chips hat also wer weniger
mister kaká
der muss dann einmal hier eingreifen
hier sind fünf challenges drin die man
machen muss
ja ich will sagen wir fangen also sandra
fängt jetzt an zum größten teil die
sache das ist mir scheißegal wer fühlt
so wir müssen das heißt ich bin jetzt
dran und wenn ich heute habe ich eine
eins bekommen wir ja es ist auch eine
frage
[Musik]
wenn jetzt wieder beim er rausspringt 36
etwas geschmeidiger und er ist immer
noch drin
[Musik]
ich hätte aber nicht geht dass da 1
wieder da kam auch nicht raus
36 mal als er spiele 32 punkte
ja ist er weiter recht bei dir da nichts
die sache ist dass ich ja jetzt schon
fünf tipps habe eigentlich das heißt du
kannst nur noch ausgleichen 33
[Musik]
der erste runde geht an sich auf jeden
der zeitmesser kaka kommt zurück hier
rein
die erste runde ist damit beendet und
sandra muss nun eine dieser fünf
challenges ziehen und dann machen
dieser darf auch sandra instagram
account eine story veröffentlichen und
die seht ihr jetzt eingeblendet sandra
ist gerade im krankenhaus
die hatte gestern im kübel seftigen
durchfall attacke neue runde
meine damen und herren 1 sandra mussten
einmal runter
kaka ist drin geblieben
[Applaus]
11 ich habe angst ich vielleicht kommt
man ja nicht raus
1 ok to say say alter 3
der japaner richtig super g gefahren
du hast du meinen ersten dinge sehen ja
ich dachte sie alles auch mal gehörig
durch das los und wenn ich da sommer das
logo zu sehen
du drückst hat auch nie richtig und
wieder zwei punkte für mich luca ganz es
sehr wichtig die akkus alter
ich bin so hast du kannst jetzt aber
firma außerdem fischerei ich habe
gewonnen
[Musik]
für die fpö ist nicht sicher ob die
schule je 100 kg sandra während uhr der
nächste challenge raussuchen kannst
leute guckt euch diese kaktus an die
kamera fokussiert mit die andere kacke
wurst
nein im ernst er will zusammen 14
schüssen dieser schade drin gehabt und
hat noch einen sonnen joker
das heißt dass man nichts machen muss
das heißt sie nur noch drei schlechte
sachen darin unter anderem einen löffel
ketchup essen ist ohne meine damen und
herren samt rad hat sah wie hast du
eigentlich logisch ich liebe meine damen
und herren 1 das ist an spannung kann
man druck traummann ist auch total wenn
die rauskommen drei alter
ein punkt besonderer nach günstiger 230
die technik weiß einfach schön hier kein
techniker haben wollen nein erstmal für
mich wissen auch nicht wer du bist jedes
mal so hier
da ist geworden ich muss jetzt mehr
gewinnen als sie da wenn ich das schaffe
ich hab kein morgen lösegeld schon zum
treffen
[Musik]
ich habe ok alter ich musste doch einmal
jetzt etwas holen
das war die taktik war überstanden und
jetzt beim gleichstand gibt es ins
stechen und beide spieler legen jeweils
eine hand an den pumpen und drücken
diese so oft bis mister kaka
herausspringen werden als erster fängt
gewinnt also müssen beide jetzt hier
dran halten
[Musik]
das nicht war okay leute ich greife mit
verbundenen nicht verbundenen augen aber
mit zwei augen in den topf rein ich
entscheide mich für dieses hier
ok ok ja eigentlich ging es wirklich
noch abfälle würden das heutige video
auf beenden wenn er freundlich ist
dennoch zwei challenges drin und zwar
einer für ketchup essen und irgendwie 20
liegestütze oder so dass wir besonders
weil der kurs hier sehr lustig gewesen
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
das gerne einen daumen hoch das anders
kanal ist in der beschreibung verlinkt
[Musik]